what does a perfect skeleton
in a great pirate story look like that
is only one of the many questions you
have to ask yourself when you're trying
to create a world like one piece
does it have an eye patch maybe some
rotten skin left on its face
of course not a real skeleton pirate
needs just
one thing and that is an afro
there we go brooke is without a doubt
one of the most creative and bizarre
characters that hero oda has created
over
all these years and as we all know that
definitely says something
even in a world where talking reindeers
giant mermaids and
other crazy figures are part of everyday
life a re-animated
music-loving and joke-cracking skeleton
with an afro
is something that catches the eye even
if it doesn't have any
but beyond his unique appearance brook
as a character
actually has a lot more to him than
meets the eye to stay with the reference
not only does he play one of my favorite
songs in anime ever
but he also represents a theme that all
of these draw hats share
but none as blatantly as brooke loyalty
there is actually a good reason that
brooke is not only one of the quirkiest
but also the oldest straw hat on luffy's
ship
with a proud 90 years on his back he had
already experienced
a lot in his life before any of the
other straw hats were even born
we actually do not know too much about
brook's early years
except that he used to serve as a
soldier in an unnamed kingdom
located somewhere in the west blue we do
not know exactly what happened during
that time
however a couple of years later brook
finally decided to set out to sea
he joined the music loving romba pirates
under the lead of captain yorkie
and together they set out towards the
grand line
on the way there they encountered the
small island way laboom
that had been separated from his hurt
brook and the others who
quickly developed a close relationship
with him decided to take the young whale
with them on their journey
upon traversing reverse mountain however
they decided to leave laboon with crocus
at the lighthouse
promising him that they would come back
for him one day and take him with them
on their journey however this wasn't
meant to happen
as parts of the crew one day caught an
incurable disease during one of their
adventures
to protect the rest of the crew those
who were infected
including brooks captain yorkie decided
to leave the ship
and try to make their way through the
combat an utterly hopeless endeavor to
say the least
after losing half of his friends brook
was appointed as the new captain
and he led his men successfully for some
time before they were attacked by
enemies upon entering the florian
triangle while they somehow managed to
get away from the fight
to their horror they had to find out
that their enemy's weapons
had been poisoned brook knowing that he
would be revived by the power of his
devil fruit suggested in tears to play
one final song together that he would
record and bring to leboon
in order to keep that promise slowly one
by one
he had to watch his friends die before
finally he also succumbed to the poison
after his soul actually returned back to
earth for
a long time he wasn't able to find his
body in the thick mists of the florian
triangle
and when he finally managed to find his
way back to the ship his body
had already turned into a skeleton
unable to
steer the ship on his own he was damned
to spend nearly
50 years in bitter loneliness finally
he stranded on thriller bark however
instead of finding new friends he had
his shadow stolen by gekkomoria
who used it to reanimate the legendary
samurai ryuma
brook tried to take his shadow back from
the swordsman but was
utterly defeated he then fled back to
his ship
and spent the next 5 years training for
the rematch
this is when brook finally meets luffy
and the other straw hats
despite being overwhelmed with joy by
finally meeting other people
he at first declines luffy's invitation
to join the crew
not wanting to be a nuisance however
after the events on thriller bark
fighting side by side with the straw
hats he finally accepts
and officially becomes the ninth member
of the crew
now as we can tell from this quite
extensive backstory
brooke has not only suffered through
many hardships and tragedies in his life
but has also already had a great deal of
character development
even before the start of the story
itself keep that in mind because
this is something that will become
important again later on
before we can look at his character arc
though we first have to understand
what kind of person brook actually is
in the context of the story we know
brook as a very polite and
at times extremely eccentric personality
in the manga this is combined with a
strong sense of humor
and a bit of perverted mentality the
anime however takes this a step further
and in many cases one step too far
random jokes are often inserted at
unfitting moments and
his perverted nature is often also taken
way overboard as a result anime broke
sometimes feels
a bit like a forced running gag which is
sad
because in the manga brook's personality
appears rather charming
here the focus lies more on his
compassionate and kind side
in addition to that brook is also a very
skilled fighter
being a more than capable swordsman and
owning a very unique and powerful devil
fruit
brook is always there to fight side by
side with his friends
which rounds him off as a great
character in an action based story
brook's psychological need in the story
is rather straightforward
up until joining luffy and the crew he
heavily suffers
under the loneliness he had to endure
for almost half a century
in other words when we first get to meet
him brooke has to learn how to overcome
his
loneliness this also translates directly
to his moral need
his long time alone being disconnected
from the world
has resulted in brooke often over
expressing his emotions
while this is not something that
emotionally hurts those around him
it still often leads to a lot of
annoyance and confusion towards him
we can see this for example the first
time brook encounters his straw hats
while they're understandably terrified
about a speaking skeleton
brook forgets that they're talking about
himself and starts freaking out too
at the same time it should also be noted
however that his emotional side
is also one of brook's greatest
qualities this
best reflects in his dream which is to
finally reunite with his old friend
laboon at reverse mountain
underlying this beautiful but also
simple dream
is the famous theme of getting a second
shot at life
and making the best out of it in a world
that is centered around the idea of
dreams
brook has gotten the ultimate
opportunity to get a second chance at
living his life the way he wants
as a result of this brook holds a clear
set of values and ideals that are
closely connected to his long
and extraordinary life having spent many
years
quite literally in darkness and solitude
relationships between people are one of
the most important things for the
skeleton
he treasures being and sharing
experiences with other people
above all else no wonder then that in
close relation to this
kindness and friendship are also an
important part of that list
of course we can best see all of this in
his relationship with laboon
but brook also lives by these principles
in the adventures he shares with his
crew
he doesn't hesitate one second to
protect frankie and robin on thriller
bark
even though he barely knows them at this
point and a little later he stands in
front of kuma on sabaodi
protecting sanji and usop as the
musician of the straw hat crew
brook of course also strongly values the
power of music
which is a big part of his character in
many ways
he even uses it as part of his fighting
style as we can for example see in a
standoff with big mom
most importantly however brooke has a
strong sense of loyalty
while everyone in the crew without a
doubt shares that quality
i think brooke personifies it best not
only is he extremely loyal towards luffy
following all his orders without any
question but
he genuinely became loyal towards anyone
in the crew
at an incredible speed despite joining
the crew
only very late on in the story he
faithfully stands in front of his
newfound family
right from the start so now that we got
to understand brooke as a character a
little better
let's find out how his character has
developed over the course of the story
being the last straw hat to join the
crew with the exception of jimbei
who's an exception in more than just one
way brook's character arc so far has
been significantly different from the
other straw hats
the most important arc for him is
without a doubt thriller bark
where we get introduced to his character
as well as to his past
in a way brook's flashbacks in
themselves already serve as a
significant amount of character
development becoming a pirate setting
out to sea
meeting labour losing his crew returning
back to life
being alone and lost in the darkness for
years and years
and then finally getting his shadow
stolen from him
i think we can all agree that all of
this does something to a person
it's a very emotional and impressive
backstory
but the problem here is that it's
exactly that
a backstory we were not there to witness
any of these events as they were
happening
and even though they have largely shaped
brook into the amazing character he is
today
we didn't have the chance to witness and
suffer through all of this
with him as we could for example with
usopp
the most important character development
for brook that we were able to be a part
of
is him overcoming his loneliness and
regaining control over his life by
joining luffy
yes with the end of thriller bark brook
has finally found a new purpose in his
second chance at life
but all of this development happened
over a very short span of time
after we had just gotten introduced to
his character
the timing of brook joining left us very
little time for emotionally
integrating him properly into the ranks
of the crew as a result it
truly speaks for his personality that he
could use the little time he was given
before the time skip the way he did
he protects his new friend on sabah odi
and following ace's death
he already shows a surprising amount of
compassion and concern for luffy's
feelings
he also immediately finds the resolve to
work hard for his new captain
and get even stronger however both these
arcs make
it difficult for broke to showcase his
skills and find his niche in the crew
which is probably the reason why some
people have had difficulties
truly warming up to his character the
same problem
occurred after the time skip where
similar to the other grand line straw
hats he had a significant lack of screen
time
in brook's case this slack proved to be
a lot more impactful though than it did
for choppa robin and frankie
who all had important roles to play up
until this point
and then out of the blue whole cake
islands happened
and as if oda wanted to make up for his
previous lack of focus
it somehow developed into the most
significant arc for our skeleton since
thriller bark
somewhere in between escaping dresrosa
and leaving zou
to help save sanji brook seems to have
gained a much stronger resolve
it's very possible that his fight with
jolla as well as his fight with sheep's
head
made brook feel like he wasn't pulling
his weight maybe he felt like he needed
to make a better effort to help his
captain and crewmates now that they were
starting to face more and more powerful
enemies
what appears certain to me though is
that this was a true turning point for
his character
which felt really really good seeing
after such a long time
it just would have been really cathartic
to see that change of heart in the story
in some way or form
because it is moments like these which
make one piece
so amazing so hopefully we will get to
see more of that in the future
coming back to the arc itself however
brooke was
finally able to play a significant part
in the cruise actions for
pretty much the first time ever he takes
on many of big mom's men
giving us some amazing battle scenes
where he finally makes full use of his
truly badass powers
later he manages to retrieve a copy of
big mom's road ponet lift
that is an essential element in finding
the one piece
and then he actually single-handedly
dares to face the emperor herself
and despite being hopelessly overpowered
he stood his ground without a second
thought
he then gave a flaming speech once again
showing his great loyalty and respect
towards his captain
in which he even dares to call big mom a
young lady
while this alone would already have been
an incredible feat for him
brooke then goes on to be the one to
break mother caramel's photo at the tea
party
together with chopper he stands his
ground against katakuris and perospero's
men
defending the sunny and later he helps
carrot taking out daifuku's fleet
finally he is the one to take out zeus
from underneath big mom's feet
not only saving the ship but also
granting nami
a powerful new weapon so finally
long after joining luffy brook seems to
have found his place in the crew and has
proven
himself to be a true straw hat